raila odinga acudió en persona a
presentar su recurso ante el tribunal
supremo de kenia el candidato
presidencial que perdió las elecciones
también pudo contar con el apoyo de sus
partidarios poco antes algunos de ellos
se habían concentrado frente a la sede
del tribunal para denunciar la postura
de la comisión electoral en estas
elecciones
jones
los kenianos queremos a raila odinga
como presidente votamos pacíficamente
durante las elecciones
pero el presidente de la comisión
electoral hizo algo mal raila odinga es
quien ganó las elecciones
de elector la comisión electoral es el
organismo responsable de garantizar que
las elecciones sean justas esto último
dio el oponente de raila odinga william
ruto una estrecha victoria con poco más
de 50% de los votos la decisión se
esperaba desde hace varios días y
provocó una ruptura en la comisión
electoral cuatro de los siete miembros
del organismo anunciaron que rechazaron
los resultados unos minutos antes del
anuncio oficial connections ya pasó el
presidente de la comisión dirigió las
elecciones como si fuera el escrutador
nacional una función que no existe hoy y
su papel en la declaración de resultados
que no fueron aprobados por el pleno por
los siete comisarios hace que los
resultados sean inconstitucionales
deudas de riesgos sanz juanes de estrés
son el tribunal supremo tiene 14 días
para pronunciarse sobre la legalidad de
la votación si se anulan los resultados
debe celebrarse una nueva elección en el
plazo de dos meses desde 2002 todos los
resultados electorales han sido
impugnados en kenia en 2007 raila odinga
ya candidato rechazó el veredicto de las
urnas provocando la peor crisis
electoral de la historia del país